We've covered a lot of ground in the last few units. You've learned how to
declare variables, and I want to come back to the question, what do you do with
a variable once you've declared it. Here we have a variable, planet. It's of
type picture, and it's somehow initialized. Now I want to use the variable. I
want to call a method on it. What methods can I call? And when I pick a method,
what values should I give it? That's what the Public Interface of the Class
tells us. It tells me, which methods I can use and what values I should supply.
Let me give you an analogy. The public interface of a car is all of the buttons
and gizmos that you see here on the dashboard. A while ago, I was driving along
in this rental car I could not figure out how to turn on the dome light, so I
had to pull out the owners manual. The public interface of the class is also
described in a kind of owners manual, called javadoc. That's the owners manual
of a class or of a set of classes, let's have a look at javadoc.